hello my name is Jason Blum and I'm
gonna talk about my five favorite
classic horror movies so the first one I
would say is Rebecca Rebecca is one of
Hitchcock's earlier movies Hitchcock is
definitely my favorite horror movie
director one of my favorite parts about
Rebecca's is just the simplicity of how
Hitchcock shot her running around her
her mansion and ever had anyone else
directed it it just wouldn't it wouldn't
get under your skin the way it does in
that movie I would for sure put get out
on my list for me I loved all parts of
get out but I think my favorite scene is
when Alison and Daniel or when their
characters are talking to each other you
don't notice it the first time but when
they go for a walk and they have this
conversation with each other and what
they're talking about is kind of mundane
but the emotional underpinning of it is
very very weighted and it's such a
delicately carefully directed scene and
the best part of get out all the way
through the movie is the words that
people are saying and the emotions that
are conveyed are very very different
that's one of the reasons why that movie
is so powerful people are not just
saying how they feel they're saying very
different things
but that scene in particular really
stands out to me it's a simple scene and
it's a special special terrific scene
it's probably my favorite scene in the
movie Rosemary's Baby this isn't why
it's on my list but I think what's so
magical about the movie is the movie is
really a drama but the fact that the
movie lives as a scary great amazing
genre movie and is really a drama I
commend that I can if you know it's just
incredible filmmaking and I love the
movie I think it's a powerful movie and
it really gets under my skin every time
I see it in an incredible way Paranormal
Activity well first of all I have a
personal emotional relationship to
paranormal activity because my company
was our company was kind of founded on
the business model of paranormal
activity which is a movie made totally
independently outside the system but
released by a traditional studio and
every movie that we've done since
insidious sinister the purge get out
split the visit every movie has to a
certain degree followed the model that I
learned from going through the
experience on Paranormal Activity so it
has a special place in my heart for that
reason I actually think it's
even though it's a found footage movie
it's a very elegant movie and those two
words normally don't go together and I
wouldn't say that of any other found
footage way I'd say oh well every other
found footage movie is kind of sloppy
and Orin was readily precise we reshot
Paranormal Activity 50 times not the
whole movie but we did 50 pickups where
we'd look at it shoot a little bit look
a little bit more shoot a little bit we
did that 50 times and there's a reason
that it touched a nerve in the way that
it did it wasn't the first found footage
movie by any means Blair which they were
one movies before by which Butler which
was really the first successful found
footage movie and and Paranormal
Activity kind of reinvented that genre
because Oren's filmmaking was so precise
so that certainly gets it goes on my
list psycho which is another Hitchcock
movie so I've got two Hitchcock movies
on my list there was a ton of innovation
in Hitchcock but I also love and then I
draw a lot of parallels you know there
was a lot the same not suggesting the
creator was the same where the movies
are as one is better than the other or
anything like that but there was a lot
of the same kind of resistance I felt
like we had with paranormal activity
clearly Hitchcock had with psycho and
then a similar success the the movie was
one of his most successful movies if not
his most successful movie he was always
very frustrated because he felt like it
was never truly accepted by by
mainstream critics although eventually
it actually it actually was but um but
he was always upset that didn't happen
right away and anyway I loved I loved it
I loved it it's an incredible movie and
that would round out my top five
you